okay hi my name is Maria Rosenberg and I
am a teacher
my kids are second graders eight years
old and a common question is that the
kids give me is why is it so cold in
space so that is the question we'd like
to have the answer off thank you very
much hi Maria your question and the
question of children around the world is
very much the same why is it cold in
space well it's cold in space because
space is very large and most of it is
far away from stars so it's cold
everywhere except when you're near a
star like the Sun now when you are near
the Sun the Sun it's hot on the Sun side
and cold on the dark side and one of the
reasons that we can live here on earth
is the Earth spins around so that it
doesn't have time to really freeze over
night and doesn't have to time to really
boil on the in the daytime if the earth
didn't spin then we would be fried to
death on the hot side and we'd be frozen
to death on the cold side but we're
lucky the earth does spin